If you return to our tutorial.
We now need to orthogonalize.
80a so we need to make an orthogonal Matrix.
Either way, there are this is there there are
a few algorithms with which we can orthogonalize or even
orthonormalize a matrix this Matrix in particular.
And that is called a gram Schmidt.
Algorithm, so let me show you the Grammy Schmidt algorithm.
Let me add one thing before I return here.
So this is the this is how you denote
the dot product. This is one way
to do it.
This dot here.
Another way to denote it is like so to use
the vertical brackets.
So either this one or
to do this
two if you see this notation.
that's the same thing as that that
both of these are
you know dot product.
You call it can call this dot product because there's a dot in here you can call this
inner product because well.
They're inside the brackets.
I come here you will see.
that
and in other examples they use a brackets.
Anyway, let's see what's going on in here.
Say you have
a basis
basis we said bases.
as two conditions
first of all
So this is this is this this is the basis. This
is a set.
It has vectors V1 V2 VN.
All three vectors must span the Subspace. What's the Subspace
RN?
So let's say we talk about a three-dimensional space.
So we need three points. XYZ each
Vector must have x y z
You can have one that's two Dimension. Another one. That's
four dimensions. All three must be of the same Dimension that's condition. Number
one.
Condition number two. They must be independent. What does
it mean for two vectors to be in two vectors
to be independent?
It means that when you take the linear combination and the linear combination
is this so let's say you have two vectors.
And you have to scalars.
Multiply this scalar without Vector multiply
that's gonna but I back here at the product. It will be
equal to zero. We saw this in another example. We saw this in the last session.
So that's what a basis is. Okay for now,
just imagine it's just a matrix.
If you would to put these three columns inside.
If we would take the components of these vectors inside angle brackets,
it will be a matrix. So for not consider this
to be a matrix column one column two column three.
How do we orthogonalize?
You define a new variable or new Vector W sub
1?
And that is just identical to V sub
1.
with components or with points if you like 110
Then you will use the first Vector W sub
1 to create a new Vector W sub 2.
How do you create W sub 2?
You take Vector 2.
And subtract it from this ratio.
So you have the dot product of V2 and
the first vector
over the dot product
of the first vector
I mean exactly as you see it here.
This will become the first Vector of
the new Matrix.
This will become the new Vector of the second Matrix.
this
the new Vector of the third Matrix
so you must multiply the scalar value.
by the components of this third vector
If you do this multiplication if you want if you do the scalar product.
it gets 0
so in
Total we will get.
Yes, we'll get a new Matrix.
So the original Matrix was 1 1 0 1 2 0
0 1 2 this new Matrix will be.
This will be its first column.
This will be its second column.
This will be its.
third column
Now this is orthogonalization actually.
So these are the vectors.
of The orthogonal Matrix
These are the vectors after it has been normalized.
If we take the square root of 2 over 2, so that's two over.
You can see.
It is 0.7. What I'm trying to say is none
of these components.
the squared over to
any of these components are above one. So when
we normalize a vector
None of the points in that Vector exceed one. There will
be between 0 and 1.
if the notation is a little too overwhelming and it kind of
is
Let me simplify by taking a huge back to
colab.
Okay.
So let's actually use this as an example.